again good evening everyone give us a
moment while i get
everything set up for our session and
say hi to miriam
hi
here i'm in california but good evening
to others
starting our live stream so it takes a
moment
oh yeah we've we've had to switch to
online formats for
faculty interviews and so we're
super familiar with the
additional setup
it looks to me like the stream is live
so we're just about ready to start
as i said welcome to everyone uh good
evening good morning depending on where
you are in the world
uh to our career master class
part of a series about how ambition
cannot be locked down so today's session
is
readjusting your career success
strategies for the pandemic
and some proven career growth hacks for
2022 are
guests today is miriam beast creek
the academic operations manager at the
buyer's eye institute at stanford
university school of medicine
um
my name is stuart creek so there's a
personal relationship here and she is
my eldest daughter so hi miriam
and
just to remind folks
about the use of webex
um
you can put your questions for miriam in
the q and a box and the these questions
will get compiled and i'll ask her the
questions in the q a section of the
presentation
uh if you put in a chat it should just
allow you to send that to all panelists
other participants won't see your
message
but we will and
so again if you have a question from
miriam best to put it in q a if it ends
up in chat we'll try to catch it there
as well
um we do have a couple of polls today
during the presentation and just to get
us warmed up let us start with the first
question here
which is
how much experience do you have
part two how are you feeling today
if you are in the
um
live stream watching on youtube
you can put your answer into the
comments
um
we asked that second question by the way
during this pandemic because
it's affected people
in different ways so
we hope that you're all doing well
we'll see in about 10 seconds from now
what the results of the poll
are yeah
so miriam this is a
broadly balanced group of people in
terms of uh years of experience
with uh the biggest cohort being people
with ten or more
um
fortunately everybody's doing pretty
much in the middle or thumbs up we do
have about a sixth of the respondents
who said they're not doing so well today
so
hopefully after they hear some
of your
advice
that will give them a better outlook and
with that
i will
introduce you formally to the audience
as i mentioned miriam is the academic
operations manager at the buyer's eye
institute of stanford university school
of medicine
her position makes her a human resources
executive there
who is responsible for helping
all of the
stakeholders that work at the institute
to develop their careers with their
fullest potential
and her background is in psychology she
has a ba from the university of
california santa cruz and a master's
from argosy university so
she uh is a
well qualified expert and we're glad to
have her and miriam
yeah thank you so much stewart for
having me this morning it's nice to be
back with simply learn i know i did a
webinar right around the beginning of
the pandemic
and so it's kind of nice to be able to
share some updates and i'd like to start
by kind of going over my journey with
stanford both pre and post lockdown
um so i started with stanford in
september of 2018. i was hired as the
human resources and faculty affairs
administrator
uh and i'll be honest i didn't know what
faculty affairs really was but i looked
into it and found out that you know
faculty affairs is what i call the human
resources for faculty development so i
help with the recruitment
appointment promotion
development of faculty as well as the
staff of the buyer's eye institute and i
do want to note that
kind of one of the things i want to
point out i was overqualified by this
role and by over qualified i mean that i
had an advanced degree i had experience
in another professional area this was an
administrator role
but i knew it would be a good foot in
the door and a really good opportunity
for growth you know i i knew stanford
was a good institution to work for and i
figured this would be a good opportunity
to get in i do want to note that based
on my personal situation that i was in i
was able to take this job the
compensation worked for me but i do want
to note that sometimes taking a job that
you're overqualified more for
may not work for you if the competition
isn't something that supports your your
life so i do just want to note that
um but very quickly i came in and was
able to learn the tasks assigned to me
and then during the first few months
that i was there
my manager was having some things going
on and she effectively went on leave in
the summer of 2019 so you know a little
over six months into my tenure um and at
that time i was able to kind of step in
and take over quite a few of the ongoing
open projects that she had been working
on
um i was able to very quickly make some
very
high impact
changes
and it was really visible to both
management the department chair
in my department and that was really a
great opportunity so then by november of
that year she had officially resigned
and i was named the full-time promoted
manager uh in that position
um
stewart if you want to answer the next
so i do want to note that
this concept of being at the right place
at the right time is something i really
am aware of happened with this role if i
had not had the manager leave at that
time if i hadn't been in the position i
was in
i wouldn't have just been able to walk
into a management role at stanford
on to the next one
so as we know in march of 2020 that's
when lockdown started at least here in
california uh march of 2020 was right in
the middle basically of where i am now
in my journey of stanford um again i'd
only been there about a year and a half
i was a new manager i was managing human
resources during an extremely impactful
time
and so in this very short period of time
things kind of had to shift even more
um
i was able to take over sending out
communications to the department
because i have a background in
counseling
i was finding that i had employees that
i was working with who are far more
distraught than usual it wasn't just
about work anymore it was about our
personal lives our health our safety
security we were very very lucky in our
department that we had no layoffs from
the pandemic we only had one layoff
during that time and it was because it
was a grant funded project that ended
but nobody had to
lose their job in our department so we
were very fortunate to have that happen
so during this time
i actually was so successful in the role
that i proposed taking over another
service area around the end of 2020 and
that was our education programs and
to be transparent the first job i
applied for in this department was the
residency and fellowship manager so
managing education programs but at that
time they were
more interested in having me come into
the hr and faculty affairs realm so it
kind of came full circle
and by january of 2021 i was promoted to
the academic operations manager as i had
now three service areas i include
education our education programs include
a accredited residency program we have
six clinical fellowships and we also
have various international rotations for
both clinical and research scholars from
around the world so it's a pretty big
impact um and so by the end of this
three-year journey you know september
just came by i went from managing a
staff of three before the pandemic
started and none when i started at
stanford to now my staff is eight
and from the time i started at stanford
my salary has increased 80 percent
uh 26
since the lockdown started i checked my
numbers this morning so clearly i was
able to not only progress before the
lockdown but actually had this amazing
period of professional growth since the
lockdown happened and i really attribute
that to
some of the skills that i had from other
jobs and
from not being a specialist in my role
so we're going to go to a second poll
now we'd like to know where people are
working from are you working from home
fully do you sometimes visit your office
or in a hybrid situation
are you fully in the office are you
between opportunities
so our role right now we are most of us
are hybrid we do go into the office one
to two days a week since we have service
areas that directly serve client-facing
populations with our students our
faculty and our staff
but for example our finance team has
been fully remote
i know i've seen a lot of companies
announcing their plans to stay fully
remote
our company right now is kind of in a
whatever works for the team situation
we'll see how that goes
well so it looks like we have a majority
of people are fully remote
we have several who are between
opportunities and then we have a pretty
even split between hybrid and fully on
site
and we definitely recognize that you
know based on your role you might need
to be on site for example we have bench
scientists in our department and of
course they can't
you know take care of mouse colonies or
perform viral assays when they're
working remote so thank you everyone
let's go ahead to the next slide
i just wanted to make a comment
there's been a
number of
studies recently that have
talked about the difference between
essentials and remotes
and it's kind of um counter-intuitive
the the words
because
essentials mean people who are
who have to be on site so it's essential
for them to be
you know out making deliveries or
working at the lab bench or that type of
thing and
remotes are people who can do their work
from
home but
it doesn't really reflect who's
essential to the company and
so
it's a little bit confusing there so
you you spoke about your personal
journey and
can you um
comment to folks about
how
agility and adaptability helped you in
that and also how that will help them
absolutely so i want to kind of address
what does it mean to be agile and to be
adaptive
and so agility you can think of is being
able to move or in this case think and
understand quickly and adaptable means
you're able to adjust to new conditions
so of course right away the pandemic
required both of these because we had a
very sudden change you know some people
had the the presence of mind to start
planning as they saw how things were
going coming out of wuhan
um and other companies you know we
we went to work on a friday and then
that monday we were told everyone's
working from home so
um of course it necessitated a kind of
quick pivot to this new working
environment and you had to adapt to new
rules new regulations
um new socioeconomic pressures
the socio-political sphere was very
charged here in america um but i want to
address again this idea of right place
at right time because it sounds like
it's just luck it's just serendipity oh
i happen to be
you know in this department when the
manager left and it just worked out but
that's that's not really the case you
can increase your chances of being in
the right place at the right time by
being agile by being adaptable by having
an expanded set of skills in your tool
belt because the more things you can do
the more gaps you can fill the more
opportunities will come and the more
places you can end up in that will lead
to these offers for advancement
so you can draw from your experiences i
did not have a linear path to get to my
current position i
have retail experience i used to work in
a residential home for children when i
was doing my master's degree i have
therapeutic experience with children and
adults
i had not ever had a formal hr position
before but i had been an academic
counselor i had worked with people i've
taught psychology courses and so i
really knew that i had a wealth of
experience to draw from so that
i could understand the conceptual
knowledge that i needed for my role and
then i could learn the skills the
technical things that i needed
the more open you are to learning the
more you're able to challenge and change
yourself
you'll find that those opportunities
grow you know it would have been a very
easy
path as far as a linear path to finish
my master's degree
find a job where i could get the hours i
needed to be a
licensed therapist and then be a
therapist but i knew when i finished my
degree that wasn't the path i wanted so
i took all of these different
experiences i had i drew on my training
and i
reformatted my career into something
that i felt i really wanted to do and
that would offer more opportunities to
move forward
the next slide please
so one of the things that i wanted to to
ask is over the past 12 to 18 months you
know about the pandemic length and
giving a little period for adjustment
how satisfied have you been with growth
opportunities in your current role um if
you're currently between opportunities
you can address you know previous roles
or even as a job seeker and you know
opportunities for growth or for
roles further than your your skill set
so we're seeing if you're very satisfied
somewhat satisfied kind of in the middle
somewhat dissatisfied or very
dissatisfied
again this is for growth opportunities
i will say that's probably one of the
the issues i had brought up to me very
quickly by several people
they were concerned about
did this lockdown mean well yes i have
my job i have security but do i still
have an opportunity to grow
and so having to balance both this idea
of
you know keeping things stable with
being able to move things forward was
very important
so it looks like we have a pretty
pretty big split um with not too many of
you being very satisfied
it's kind of all centered in the middle
there some are very dissatisfied which i
am sorry to hear that but hopefully
again you know some of this information
can help you to to think of ways that
you can
kind of grab the bull by the horns a
little bit um
and then of course we hope as
institutions adjust to our new normal
we'll see people having more robust kind
of remote training and growth
development plans
stuart did you have any comments on this
one
it's interesting there's two comments
one on agility which uh
early in the pandemic
i attended an online webinar and
the executive said if they had told us
that we needed to move everyone to work
from home
um we would have said sure give us six
months and 10 million dollars we'll get
it done
and in the event she said
we got it done in two days with no
budget so
that's the kind of um
exactly agility that we've all been
forced into in a certain way um as far
as growth opportunities uh yeah i've
also had an eclectic career and
sometimes there have been growth
opportunities other times
it seems like
you're in a slot and
that's
kind of where everybody sees you so
it is
good to know that there are ways to look
around that and look past that
so
we talk about how ambition can't be
locked down and things that have been
some things have been limited but you
know what are the things in your opinion
that
haven't been limited by the
circumstances of pandemic
oh yeah i mean obviously i think the
thing that comes to mind the most with
what has been limited is the ability to
interact face to face to
congregate to get into groups with
people um and i think for a while that
was really hard for people to adjust to
um but some things have definitely not
been limited and i actually think that
the quite the opposite your ability to
pursue learning has if anything grown
because there is a new credence to
online and self-directed learning that i
i did not see before i will say that
when i came into my hr role i had a few
managers i worked with who
if they saw a professional school on
your resume or that you indicated you
went to an online degree they had a bias
that that wasn't as good that you
weren't as skilled that you didn't have
as much knowledge as those who had done
an in-person learning experience
my master's degree was was hybrid and
you know i i needed to work while i was
doing my master's i couldn't become a
full-time traditional student again
and so i knew when i came into hr that i
valued online degrees i valued those who
can demonstrate that they were able to
juggle education with a job with their
life
i think that shows
tremendous resilience
and a
an ability to really be successful in
roles that require
a lot of prioritization of really
understanding your own skill set so i
absolutely encourage people right now to
you know use this time where you might
have slightly more flexibility without
having to commute
where you're realizing that your company
is allowing you to have flexibility with
your hours
pursue learning opportunities you know i
took
finance for non-finance managers just a
few weeks ago
um and it was really
really helpful and it wasn't something
that before i'd had kind of the time to
do because i couldn't find a strong
online format and stanford luckily with
continuing studies offered a very strong
online class that i was able to take in
the evenings
um if you want to go ahead and advance
to the next slide
so as we've already addressed this need
for agile flexible employees has not
been limited if anything it's grown if
anything we need to see that people were
able to successfully transition to this
new market to this new world of
increased digital communication of
increased accountability and
independence in our jobs
so there's been constant changes in the
social climate in the policy
landscape we've had to send emails to
the department saying you know that
email you just got from central hr don't
do anything the policy changed yesterday
please hold um and that takes a certain
amount of adaptability of ability to
think on your feet uh and and being
flexible includes being flexible with
what you see as your perfect path
you know if if you stay really focused
on okay i want to be a project manager
like i have to be a project manager
you might block out other opportunities
for growth you might not take a role
that project management isn't the main
duty but you'll get exposed to it and
therefore grow you might not take a role
with a company where
you know the job isn't exactly what you
want it to be but they have very strong
benefits for
uh staff development and you can take
advantage of those benefits
to develop your learning uh so it's
really important to recognize you know
who's gonna move forward in this
environment and who's going to
kind of limit themselves or be limited
by the environment versus adapting
changing and flexing with the
environment
you can go on to the next slide
and then opportunities you know i of
course understand this we have
participants from all over the world but
i wanted to quickly share some data in
the u.s just in this was from september
of 2021 they added
000 jobs unemployment fell the hourly
wage went up so as much as it might feel
like it's not the right market right now
there are opportunities they again might
not be the exact opportunity you want it
might not be that perfect fit
but if anything i want you to take away
from this webinar that
what you you don't need to fit the the
round peg into the square hole you need
to learn how to become a square peg when
you need to be one if that makes sense
you can go ahead to the next slide
and then of course we need to address
yes
that's an interesting metaphor to become
the square peg
when you need to to be one
um and being able
to uh
pull in the things you're not using at
the moment and push out the other skills
that you have had in reserve is a
interesting way of changing shape that
way absolutely
you can't change your environment too
much usually i can't have changed where
i was in stanford when i first started
but what i did find was
that you know i started as the square or
the round peg to use that metaphor
and as i pulled in more information as
other parts came out like you said i
suddenly found that i was able to fit
into the need that i took what was
needed took what i knew how to do and
synthesize those together and i didn't
have the perfect resume my director told
me
about a year into my time at stanford
that he straight up would not have hired
me with my resume but i happened to
have had good references and i was very
persistent
um and he's very glad he hired me
because it worked out for what he ended
up needing
um it's not always just the job that's
posted that is the true need so there
you go
that leads us to another part of agility
that
the world
has been getting more digital
for a number of years
it's a big trend in
the working world and in enterprises
before the pandemic and after the
pandemic
it became a matter of business survival
for companies to be able to
do work online to offer products online
to
support interactions with customers
online
and suppliers online so
um
you can see from the illustration
the person who's working in a lab or a
person who's a healthcare worker
might not have thought of themselves as
a digital worker but now
today
it's necessary to know
how to
do your work using digital tools
and that applies across the board to
almost every field so
let's talk a little bit if you will
about um
how people need to be
open to transforming as the world around
them transforms the digital
yeah you know i'd like to to even share
that so i work in an eye institute we
work in an ophthalmology department
and very quickly our doctors realized
that telehealth was going to be
difficult
for ophthalmologists because they need
to be able to examine your eye so we've
actually seen some amazing advancements
in this short time with instruments that
can attach to iphones that can
facilitate much more efficable eye exams
we also have had doctors who have become
credentialed out of state so that they
can read
imaging and things like that and and
even in that sphere in the healthcare
realm uh we've seen this boom of digital
and technologically kind of
um
sponsored transactions or whatever so
absolutely digital work affects every
every industry right now so
one thing that i've noticed especially
for for our teams for the operational
staff is there's more of a need to
identify and self-identify development
opportunities my manager is not right
down the hall anymore we're not talking
daily you know popping in
having those kind of offhand chats about
oh this is kind of what i want to do
so there's
this need when you're at home and you're
doing work there's not someone there to
turn to and say hey how do i do this
really quick there's this need to kind
of enhance your own skill set and what
i've done is actually found some gaps in
my institutional knowledge if i know
where i am right now and i know the next
step is potentially a director position
i need to go outside of the
areas that i'm already comfortable in
and i need to learn grants
administration as i shared i was taking
a finance class these are the gaps in my
own knowledge and these are the areas
i've self-identified
that will lead to new things they're not
the areas that i need to learn right now
in my current role to keep doing my job
well they're the areas i need for the
next role for my next opportunity and so
this is a great experience right now for
me to say okay
when i'm at home doing my work and i
know that there's something i need how
can i learn to do this how can i find
the resources that i need to allow me to
do this effectively
and if you want to go ahead to the next
slide
this ties into this idea of a
self-service model so i'm not sure how
it has been with your companies or
places you've worked um but we've really
tried to increase this idea of
self-service
i
love when my employees when my staff
say oh you know that thing that i asked
you about i emailed you the other day
you know i don't need it anymore i
actually figured it out on my own i love
it even more if they don't email me
first and they figure it out but
those who know how to use their
resources wisely how to independently
and proactively evaluate if they need
assistance or if they have the tools to
complete a task
those are going to be the most
successful employees they can find
information they can use that
information effectively
it's not to say that i'm not there to
support my team or that management
doesn't have
a
responsibility to provide adequate
training and support but the ones that
are going to really excel are the people
who who have found ways to adapt to this
digital environment and still move
themselves forward still propel their
careers
um so i really can't encourage you
enough to
think about
if you were your own academic advisor if
you were your own career counselor if
your friend came to you for help what
would you tell that person
what would you say
you know
that you need to learn more of what
skills do you need to develop so i
really encourage you to think about all
the resources out there don't limit
yourselves to the the ones that are
immediately available or easiest to find
do the research to find the ones that
work for you
to the next
and then interpersonal skills look
different so
as we've already talked about we can't
gather face to face in most instances we
do have some people who are working in a
hybrid environment like myself
where you are going in you are having
chances
to
interact face to face
but i would say 95 of my interaction
with people at work these days is in a
digital setting or
rarely on the phone but most of it's
texting
instant messaging emails and zoom
it's not the same as connecting in
person i can't make eye contact
in the same way i can't you know right
now i'm not looking directly at the
camera as i'm speaking
um you know if we were in a room
together i'd be speaking to all of you
we aren't able to have
physical contact you know in those
serious moments where
you know a hug
or just a hand on the arm might be
helpful um even things like i've had to
to lay off and and terminate people and
doing that in a zoom setting is so
uncomfortable it's very impersonal of
course there's this kind of protection
that comes with it
but you can't have that same
kind of unspoken
physical interaction energy that happens
so in a digital world you have to kind
of take that extra step you need to be
more intentional with your connections
and you also need to remember not only
to connect with those in your sphere of
direct influence if i only talked to my
staff and my director and then the
faculty that i'm serving
how would i know about what other
departments are doing how would i know
about what best practices to adopt for
my own work how would i learn about new
opportunities with other
organizations or you know even i have a
colleague in another department who
is very into data analytics and she will
when we connect she will share different
courses that she's taken she will share
you know information and resources
and i have to make sure that i'm
intentionally
reaching out to the people that i would
normally maybe get to see at an all
hands on deaf hr meeting or that i might
attend a regular debriefing with
so interpersonal skills i cannot
emphasize enough
are important and especially if you're
interviewing digitally
you want to be able to come off as warm
and personable and how do you do that
when you're sitting behind a camera
maybe with a fake background you know
maybe have a cat on the ground meowing
at you kids running around in the back
um
vulnerability authenticity those are
also helpful we're at a point with
almost every
interaction we have if someone has kids
around and they start to apologize it's
not a problem i understand
um you know don't don't be ashamed to
bring your full self into your
interactions and especially when we're
all in our homes that's really important
as i say that there's a cat
if you want to go ahead to the next
slide
and then finally uh or stewart did you
have any commentary okay
there's
i think a rule that says that if your
cat climbs into the camera view you have
to hold it up to the camera so i can see
it but
that's just me because i'm a cat person
like you
um
so
we kind of
as i've talked about before there's
there's times when you feel like you're
in in a
a pigeonhole a slot that they've picked
for you
um
and
you want to break out of that
you want to
see different um opportunities for
yourself or a different future for
yourself
um
so
let's talk a little bit about
how visualizing that future and setting
those goals
and how to set those goals
um because we've had
questions
coming in through the chat from people
who are
looking to get their first job there are
questions from people who have
been laid off for that type of thing and
they're people who want to get out of a
stagnant situation so
can you talk about how goal setting
helps with that
absolutely so i think one of the
most important things to think about is
this idea of intentionality and
cultivation um anyone who's ever tried
to grow something so i i kill everything
i try to grow except succulents i can
keep those alive um and that's because i
realize i don't have enough
will and intentionality in my gardening
to keep other things alive that's fine
um but
in your career you can cultivate almost
any skill or quality you really can it
takes intentionality it takes practice
so no matter your learning style if
you're a visual an auditory learner if
you need to be hands-on there are ways
to develop yourselves um and it doesn't
always matter about your your access to
resources you do not have to
take a course in public speaking and
have that on your resume
to develop your public speaking skills
you can join toastmasters if you have
that available to you i had an old
colleague who was
whatever is a master toast master when i
was out in hawaii and
he was just a phenomenal speaker and it
was through years and years of
storytelling and practice and in any
meeting he was in he knew how to make
his point how to express himself how to
use his time wisely it was phenomenal
but none of us have have access to
toastmasters form a group of friends i
don't know how many of you heard about
powerpoint parties they were kind of big
last year when people were really locked
down and that was just this idea of
getting together with a group of friends
or colleagues
and taking 10 to 20 minutes to do a
short powerpoint on an area of interest
to you and what's the point of that it
helps you learn how to use your time
wisely how to create visuals how to
impart information effectively in a
digital environment
it's tremendously important it's so
important that that's what i have my
team doing right now
coming up to the end of the year we're
using our team meeting time and they're
each doing 20-minute
presentations on something in their
service area because i noticed right
away that we had an issue with
presenting in a digital audience they
really needed that opportunity to
practice
and if you don't have that access if
you're by yourself speak out loud to
your pets
that's fine uh stuart i think we moved
ahead a little in the
slides
um but even if you if you don't have
someone around if you have pets if you
have kids
you can perfect you can figure out ways
to practice your public speaking even if
it's in the mirror
sometimes just practicing something over
and over and over
makes you good at it um
if you are trying to learn about excel
just go online and grab data sets you
don't have to have real data to work
with when i was teaching statistics i
used to just make up data sets for the
students to run
sample t-tests on it doesn't have to be
you know overly thought out but you can
cultivate skills sometimes though it's
important to figure out what those
skills are
um and then also to recognize where your
previous experiences even if not
obviously related are going to help you
and with that if we go to the next slide
one thing we really want to think about
is how much are we limiting ourselves so
i know that there's probably several
people who are thinking okay this is
helpful for working professionals i
haven't started work yet
especially those of you who maybe don't
have the most traditional path don't
limit yourself don't think of periods of
unemployment as weaknesses don't think
of periods where maybe you've had to
focus on family as disruptions in your
career path
but in essence those are
completely unique experiences
that
require a tremendous amount of problem
solving of agility of adaptability so i
really encourage people to start talking
about your unusual career path start
practicing
how you would talk to someone if you met
them in a networking opportunity about
the fact that you haven't been working
for a while but what have you learned
what have you done while you haven't
been working what has
needing to be
thrifty helped you to learn what has
you had to prepare budget for yourself
have you had to
teach children at home are you suddenly
you know multitasking between job
searching
and um homeschooling these are all
um
oh what's the word
these are all assets that you can bring
i have
several people that i work with
who
are first generation have had to care
for elderly parents and i the amount of
work that it takes and coordination that
it takes to care for an elderly parent
these people are amazing schedulers they
are absolutely fantastic project
managers they really know how to work
with people and those aren't skills that
you can just necessarily
learn only in a job environment learn
only in a professional setting
so then oh and i also just want to note
there's also a huge shift in the united
states and many industries towards
looking at what we think of as dei
diversity equity inclusion the way
stanford has been conceptualizing that
is actually what we're calling distance
traveled so we want to hear about your
path we want to hear about your journey
from
where you started to where you are now
and respecting understanding and mostly
valuing those unique experiences i'm
seeing that so much more than i've seen
in any other
time of working in any other social
climate or climate
climate where people really are valuing
the ability to
kind of come through something
resiliently and that includes periods of
unemployment
and so i think we have another poll
um
i see a different poll there we go my
manager supervisor the organizational
leadership does a very good job of
developing employees true or false and
again if you're not working right now if
you were somewhere previously you can
answer off that
and it's also helpful to think about
in this case not your own role in your
development but the supervisor manager
or leadership's role because i would say
i don't necessarily have an especially
strong manager for development um i've
developed myself
but that
i've been able to take advantage of
resources from the institution
that are very helpful
seconds left
and i see that we have
the most most of us over half responded
false and of course not everyone
participated um and i am sorry to hear
that but i also again think that's why
it's so important to really think about
what you can do to fill those gaps for
yourself
and then that takes us to our final
section
all right so
i think this is
a
kind of the highly anticipated part of
the presentation about
how
what kind of practical steps people can
take
to
ensure that their career is moving the
way they want it
sure so this is you know
this is the the hard part is we all we
all want to control our career destiny
and we can't but there's some things
that we can do to kind of help guide us
on that path that we want to make it
more preferable
and one of those is really
it might be counterintuitive but be a
generalist
don't just limit your learning and your
development to a narrow area there's
there's generalists and there's
specialists right um i was reading an
article preparing for this and this one
phrase really stuck out to me and that
was that the multi-utility players fill
succession boxes while specialists fill
the roles so i really want you to think
about that
and there's nothing wrong with being a
specialist you can develop and and be
very skilled in your one area
but if if advancing into the c-suite or
if
leading a diverse team that takes on
many different service areas is your
goal you really need to diversify your
skill set
um i've had experience working with
children i've had experience with cash
handling and retail management and
dealing with difficult customers and all
of these things really fed into my
success at working in hr
um at servicing faculty right
so if you have the opportunity to take
you know finance class for non-finance
majors
to
understand you know if you work in an
organization where they're applying for
grants look at the grant
application cycle look at compliance
understand what an irb is
understand what they're doing in
research and development you know it
doesn't mean you have to go get multiple
degrees and have certificates in
everything you do
but a more generalized path the more
general knowledge you bring the more
perspective you're gonna have the more
you're gonna be able to synthesize all
these different parts when you're
looking at a problem and potentially the
more effective you'll be so again i
really want you to think about this idea
of
who do you see moving up what are those
people's experiences and credentials
i personally do not see a whole lot of
people with a very linear path in the
positions that i report to most of them
have diverse experiences
and they draw on those diverse
experiences they see them as beneficial
not as something they have to apologize
for
if we go onto the next slide
the other thing to think about too is
when you're setting goals
being realistic and setting short and
long-term goals is important
so earning a certificate maybe three or
four classes is more of a short-term
goal i have a certificate in community
college faculty preparation that was a
one-year program
that i did before i started teaching
that was really really beneficial
and the last part of it was an
externship where i was placed in a class
and i ended up actually teaching that
person's class after they left
um that was a short-term goal that
actually helped with a longer-term goal
i had of becoming a faculty member
um but even further than that you know
if you're thinking of advancing into the
c-suite
again if you want to be a project
manager program manager
you really want to think about what are
those shorter term goals i need to to
get through um for those of you who are
in school right now or just finishing
school
that was a huge goal and it was really
more of a long-term goal when you think
about it but now you have to start
setting smaller goals even if that
smaller goal is just i'm going to send
10 resumes today
those are small goals and the more you
can set those the more you can kind of
see little wins along the way the more
momentum you'll keep up and the more
motivation
and it's also just it doesn't make sense
to have a one
narrow long term goal that you're
looking at without trying to figure out
in between
what are those things that are going to
help me to achieve more
happiness more stability whatever it is
right now
and those short-term goals are going to
be very important for that
so for me for example my short-term goal
is to finish there's a curriculum that i
can do for free at stanford on grants
management because i work so closely
with faculty who have to apply for
grants i want to understand what they're
going through
and then finally i know people say this
all the time but i i especially right
now in this environment of
not always being as connected my last
my last tip is really to seek mentorship
you want to head to that last slide
connect with those who have careers you
admire or achievements you admire don't
just say okay well this person also has
an mba so i'm just going to ask them
are they in a position that you want to
be in are they
kind of at a at a place in their career
where they seem to be happy they seem to
be thriving and it's something you want
to be able to
um replicate in your own
it's so important to get insight from
people who have been there and
especially for people who are from
underserved
or under resourced backgrounds if you
can connect with someone who
not has the exact same life experience
but who's also had to
go through things that maybe the
majority groups have not had to
that can also really help to be able to
see
there is a way forward there are going
to be hurdles it is going to be hard but
so and so did it this is how they did it
i can do it too
um i am very very very lucky to have
several people in my
past that have been excellent mentors
sometimes they've also been my managers
i know that's very rarely the case
but it's it's just so important to
really understand
how having someone who isn't
responsible for your performance
appraisal who isn't involved in the
day-to-day dynamics
can give you some perspective can give
you some
insight and guidance on what it's going
to be like for you on your journey and
even just having that person to connect
with to be in your corner can be very
helpful
um
you know it's hard sometimes to find a
mentor i definitely recommend
if there's virtual conferences you can
go to webinar type things if there's any
virtual networking opportunities
presented those are great opportunities
we just did a mixer for our mentorship
program in the school of medicine and it
was amazing how much you can actually
learn about each other in such a short
time
all right and that brings us i believe
to our
final poll
stuart
this is a poll that asks about some of
the things that simply learn does
um having to do with business and
digital skills
so as miriam said it's important to be
what some people call the t-shaped
uh
professional where your skills are broad
across the different
categories that's the top of the t
and then they're deep in your area
specialty
forms the
body of the tea so
here's a question a chance to
think about what you'd like to add to
your repertoire or what you'd like to
deepen your experience in
and when you'd like to
do that
so we have the answers
and it's interesting because the pattern
follows the list of skills in order
um
from the most popular to
least more or less
with business and project management
the most interest
and it's good to see that about half of
the respondents here said they'd like to
get started right away which is
always the best time to get
started on
something that will take you closer to
your goal
thank you for that
and
from that we're going to go into the q a
and uh
going to
all right we're on and i will pull up
the questions
so we have a few
um
so rahul
um
has just a comment but i thought it was
kind of an ironic one it said he found a
great opportunity to make a career
transition
uh in a new direction
that happened during the pandemic
the only drawback is he did it when he
lost his job
so
that's when a case of a person being
agile flexible
in the face of the challenges and
being forced into a shift that he didn't
necessarily want to make at that time
uh um
redhimar has a question um
and this one i think
you're specifically
best at
answering balancing work and growth
opportunities online can be tricky
and sometimes i feel burnout and it
takes a lot of toll in my mood for
growth and upskilling
do you have any advice for this personal
issue you know i i agree i
there were nights when i had my finance
class and i just had a long day and i
didn't really want to deal with it um
i think that
the most important thing i can tell you
is to have a kind of mind for self-care
to recognize where your energy is being
allotted and to do your best to kind of
create boundaries and i know that can be
hard i know not every work environment
is amenable to creating boundaries but
you know one thing that our team really
tries to do is we have a stop time where
we're not supposed to ask each other for
things if you're working after five
that's fine i'm not working after five
um and we kind of do that to help each
other have boundaries i also you know if
there's ways to find
making your development fun
i know that sounds silly but you know if
there's someone that you can study with
if there's kind of a
non-traditional way that you can get
those skills some of the um online
courses too some of the people putting
out online courses
really it's almost kind of entertaining
while you're taking them so reading
reviews from people
seeing what what they're saying about
these things and then don't
feel like you have to force yourself or
rush yourself i know it's hard to be
patient especially if you're in a job
you don't really love
or if you're between work and you're
feeling the pressure
um
but this this is stuff that takes some
time
it's you know there's some several
people i've talked to where it's really
been a better idea for them to take
maybe a part-time job or even something
totally you know customer service
oriented while they're finishing their
degree or while they're finishing a
certificate program so they have that
ability to bring in some income
while they're still focusing on their
longer term goal
um but really you know it's just about
trying to have those boundaries when you
can and trying to find opportunities for
rest
you know if there's if there's days you
can do less zoom if you're a very zoom
heavy person or less looking at the
computer if there's lessons you can
listen to
and then do the work things like that
try to break up the different you know
not to stand a computer all day um that
can be
difficult yeah
we also had a past webinar i think you
can find it on our
simply learn youtube channel on
thinking it was with
matt bailey
and
was
uh
no jeff allen maybe
on product project management techniques
and one of i bring it up because one of
the techniques he talked about was time
boxing
where
his advice is
segment your day so that you have
specific amounts of time that you will
work on a particular task
so
i'm going to work on this task for 30
minutes
work on the task for 30 minutes stop
move on to the next task so that you
don't get sucked into something
and keep working on it until you turn
out so
there's some resources
you can look at there
um
and christian
keita asks
um
you know his
his comment was the feeling of
presentations highly helpful for a
current professional but for someone
who's looking to land a job what advice
do you have for somebody who's into it
and it relates to another question
um
from abiel who asks aren't companies
looking for particular experience rather
than general
sure so you know it of course depends on
the role when we hire a financial
analyst they have to have financial
experience i can't convince someone who
has no financial experience that they're
going to fit into that right um
and i'm not saying you know walk into
something you're completely unqualified
for and just convince them you can do it
if there are particular skills you need
to have or certifications absolutely
pursue those
but what i'm what i'm kind of suggesting
is don't limit yourself to only looking
at the jobs that have the title you
think you want if it says data scientist
that's great but there's a lot of other
jobs even my my residency coordinator is
starting to learn tableau so that she
can do some things with people analytics
in our programs
look for jobs that will offer you ways
to
gain on the job experiencing something
if you know you want to be a project
manager one day on you know different
technical things
you don't have to necessarily take a job
with a tech company you can take a job
in education you can take a job for a
non-profit learn those skills in other
ways i know it's very difficult to um
with interviews so i recommend literally
practicing i've had friends that i do
mock interviews with
having that ability to
run through
your your own little pitch about
yourself to go through your experience
and to get feedback from someone can be
so helpful
i had someone this is the first time in
my whole life that i've actually had
someone at the end of an interview we
did together stop and say do you mind if
i ask how do you feel that went how was
the interview i was not the decision
maker i was not the hiring manager for
the role so i felt like you know it was
appropriate to talk to her about it
but when you can ask for that feedback
and don't say well what did i do wrong
you know just how was that you know do
you have any advice for how i could have
better articulated this particular point
um get that feedback when you can
i i can't recommend enough
practicing not rehearsing so that you
have a script that you're giving
but practice talking about how
oh during this period of unemployment
i've actually developed quite a good
skill set for you know detail
orientedness and time management i've
been managing my job search i have 15
open
applications that i'm working towards i
stay in contact with everyone i'm
following up and that's a skill set that
i can bring to this role because it's
taught me x y and z
um it's it's again not about taking
something so far away from what they're
looking for and making it work but the
things you might not think of
traditionally really are assets they are
ways to develop skills that apply
to work
one quick comment and the last question
quick comment from frank perez who
points out the panic that
a lot of executives
organizational managers feel
because of the push for digitalization
for digital transformation
um
changing their business models changing
the way they work changing how they can
manage people
and it's a whole new world that they
have to adapt to so they're feeling a
lot of
stress and panic from that
the last question is i think you may
have answered it in your last answer but
michael asks
how do you convince a company to hire
you during a pandemic
you know
that's a hard question um we're doing a
lot of interviewing right now and i have
for example a candidate that i
i need her no matter what i don't even
have a position for her yet but i want
her
and for me what it is is she has been
able to
explain to me how her skill set which is
nothing like it's not what i'm looking
for it's it's it's not not what i'm
looking for it just doesn't have exact
experience that matches she's basically
been able to tell me exactly how she is
going to come in and add value right
away
she understands the role she asked when
i first started talking to her to meet
with the other person that's already on
my team in that role to get a better
understanding of what the day-to-day
would be like she took advantage of the
fact that we have resources available
publicly online at stanford for the
different roles so she did a little
research into
based on the posting and some of the
words used in the posting figuring out
kind of what it would be like and it was
just so impressive to me that
she did the research on not just the
company you know people all the time are
like oh stanford's great i want to work
at stanford she told me why she wanted
that job how she was going to
immediately become be able to come in
and make an impact she addressed the
fact that not having direct experience
wasn't going to limit her because she
has had so much experience and been so
successful that she's been able to
demonstrate that she does learn quickly
you don't want to say i'm a quick
learner show them that you're a quick
learner i can now say on my resume
in you know 10 months less than that i
went from
entry level to manager because i'm a
quick learner because i'm agile because
i'm adaptive
um those those are great opportunities
to really demonstrate
again not just that i have this exact
matching skill set and and that might
affect people differently based on the
job they're looking for but this is how
i am going to add value and make an
impact in the role and as a manager all
i heard was this is how i'm going to
make your life easier and keep the
business moving forward
the old adage of don't come to me with
problems bring me solutions right
absolutely being solutions focused i
cannot emphasize enough um
you know it's not that i don't want
people to bring up problems when they
exist
but if you constantly point out issues
with no solutions then i'm not going to
think very highly of your ability to
problem solve i'm just going to think of
your ability to
try to figure out how to not do your
work well um problem solving solutions
focused those are important and i saw
someone had a question about how do you
talk about gaps in your resume be honest
be transparent and really you know talk
about what you've learned what you've
done in that time if you've done three
or four different development
opportunities
oh my gosh that that's amazing if you've
been taking care of your kids and
balancing you know a job search those
are assets um you might not get that job
right away but stay connected to people
i've had good interviews and i send
people that i've had my interviews with
positions that are open in other
departments i've referred them to other
people
stay connected even if you don't get a
job if you can
we did have a question from somebody
that i'm responding to
talking about
whether to take a
training
a digital certification course will that
guarantee a job and i was just
mentioning
to them that
simply learn has some
some of our programs
do have job assist some of our programs
even have a job guarantee but those are
in specific areas and i never recommend
anybody going into one of those areas
unless it's something that they're
already
interested in and and would want to
build a career into because it's
usually not worth it just to take a job
just for the sake of having a job
but in this particular instance
america is saying that um she feels
pigeonholed
as a
tourism graduate and so
um
she is looking to broaden out into other
things like digital technology so
again it's it's important to know that
um so if you have questions about that
i've put into the chat box a few times
the
information about our simple learn
free program called skill up and
if you follow that link and if you go
through our website you'll encounter
some of our other courses as well skill
up doesn't include the job assist but
our other courses do and scallop is a
good way to get started in a particular
area especially if you're looking at a
transition from one career to another to
say
oh this is something i'm interested in
because i think this this video course
i'm taking is really cool and i then
decide if you want to go for a
full course that includes the
live classroom
live online classroom and that type of
thing so
um
with that
okay and they're saying that the
link is not reachable
um
if you can't get the link to work from
the chat
do copy that
and put it into your browser directly
because the link
i think
is correct
um and if not email me mike contact us
in the
emails you've been receiving about the
webinar so uh with that
i want to thank miriam for being so very
generous with her time and her expertise
um
and
i will
put into the
chat window her
are what we need to go to to become
stronger and more resilient the people i
meet who got where they are very
linearly are the people who struggle the
most when they get to those higher level
positions they're not doing well because
they're too focused on the only thing
they know the people who i see who are
most successful have a diversity of
experience that they understand how to
synthesize into the skill set needed to
be successful at work
people who have never encountered
adversity tend to crumble when they
first encounter it so absolutely you
know we had people freaking out during
the pandemic and we had plenty of people
are like i've had much worse things
happen and i'm gonna get through this
too so we will all get through this too
thank you so much
um i want to mention that we will have
another webinar uh two days from now
thursday
nine o'clock india time in the evening
and 8 30 a.m
california time 11 30
a.m east coast
it is about product development and we
have the group vice president of oracle
cx marketing trisha sofa
who will be talking about product
development product management we did
have a question from someone who's
interested in learning about product
management so
this is the perfect webinar for that i'm
going to drop the
link for that into the
chat now and again if
the link in the chat doesn't work when
you click on it copy it into your
browser
and with that
we will end the
event
the
ways you can keep in touch with stimply
learner are all basically simply learned
on our various social media
channels facebook twitter and linkedin
and um
we'd love to keep in contact with you
and we'd love
to help you with your personal career
development
we look forward to seeing you
at future simply learn webinars and as
part of the simply learn learner
community so thanks everybody for being
here
thank you
you